yesterday we received a new TV spot
trailer from marvel that had new scenes
for Avengers infinity war you can check
out the new trailer and the video I did
on it and the link above but today we'll
be talking about something that you
might have missed before we get started
I'd just like to ask you one question
would you please subscribe to my channel
also if you like our videos consider
donating to our patreon account today
we'll be talking about a very brief
scene that was released in a new trailer
yesterday Marvel uploaded the video to
YouTube Facebook and Instagram but you
would have only have noticed what we're
going to talk about if you watched it on
Instagram due to the length of the
screen and what we noticed is this
Thanos has four Infinity stones that's
right if you look closely at his
Infinity Gauntlet you can see that there
are four stones in it going in order
from left to right he has the Power
Stone the space stone the reality stone
and the mine stone from here we're going
to be talking about how he most likely
came across these stones and Avengers
infinity war so if you don't want any
potential spoilers for infinity war turn
back now let's start with the space
stone because most of the fans clearly
know by now that he gets it from Loki I
don't think Loki willfully gave it to
Thanos I think he was forced to because
we all know that Loki took the tesseract
at the end of Ragnarok then thanassis
ship pops up Thanos boards the ship that
Thor and Loki are on and one way or
another he gets the space stone
next is the Power Stone the last time we
saw the Power Stone the guardians of the
galaxy gave it to the Nova Corps for
safekeeping we know from the trailers
that have been released that the Power
Stone is the first stone that Thanos
puts inside the Infinity Gauntlet this
most likely means that Thanos paid a
little trip to Xander before he arrived
at Loki ship the Nova Corps is probably
just no match at all for him and my
guess is that he probably lays waste to
a good chunk of Xander next is the
reality stone the last we saw of the
reality stone was when the Warriors
three gave it to the collector after the
end of Thor the dark world
this is most likely the same scenario as
the Power Stone Thanos or someone from
his Black Order pays the collector a
little visit and most likely forcefully
takes away the reality stone from him
the last stone in his Infinity Gauntlet
however is a pretty big surprise to us
and that is the mind stone it's a pretty
big surprise because the mind stone
currently sits inside visions forehead
and the only way to get it from his
forehead and to his infinity gallon is
most likely to kill him we have a scene
a vision on the floor and Corvus glaive
jamming his glaive into the mine stone
and vision screaming i however do not
think this is where Thanos gets the mine
stone I think vanos gets it from him in
Wakanda we know from the trailers that
vision is brought to Wakanda to protect
the mind stone inside of him we also
have scenes of him in the battlefield
and particularly this scene where he
says and he's lying on the ground I
think that vision somehow knows that
Thanos has collected three Infinity
stones already and is in fact coming for
vision now and then I think he will
appear and attempt to retrieve the mine
stone I think Scarlet Witch will put up
a little bit of a fight as well as
vision but ultimately Thanos will
retrieve the mine stone and kill vision
the main question that has been asked
lately is can Thanos retrieve the mind
stone from vision without killing him I
think this depends on two different
scenarios
I think sharee could probably figure out
a way along with the Scarlet Witch to
get the mind stone from his head somehow
without killing him but I think if
Thanos himself goes to retrieve the mine
stone he will definitely kill vision
I do think fan OHS will retrieve it from
him in Wakanda and then we'll cut to the
scene that we have here which is him
most likely showing up to the main
battle in Wakanda but what do you guys
think do you think vision can live
without the mine stone do you think
danos just kills them for the heck of it
or do you think something completely
different let me know in the comments
below I'd love to hear your theories and
of course don't forget to like this
video and be sure to subscribe to my
channel to join the wolf gang thank you
so much for watching
woof woof
you